i'm gonna say five four three two one go
i'm gonna make a decision hey what's up
my name's samuel leeds and in this video
i'm gonna give you
my number one secret hidden skill with
how i've become successful in business
how i've become successful in property
okay this is it it is making decisions
and it is the ability to not only make a
decision and a good decision
but to make it quickly and in this video
i'm going to tell you not only why it's
really important to be able to actually
make a decision and make a decision
quickly
but also explain why rich people and
successful people
why they spend their whole life making
fast quick decisions over and over
that's how they live their life
that's how i live my life compared to
people that are not so successful
compared to maybe poor and middle people
who spend their life talking
discussing analyzing rich people come
and make the decisions
now you might disagree with me this is
just my opinion of course
let me know your comments and your
opinions below but this is definitely
my life my life i mean literally i am
just
my full-time job is a decision maker you
know i'll be speaking to my staff and
it'll be you know they'll have had a
long meeting and then they'll say what
do we what are we going to do
and if i don't quickly make a decision
all that's going to happen it's going to
put the brakes on
everything everything's going to be slow
you know shall we refinance or sell this
estate i've got to make a quick decision
shall we open up the academy events
again or should we continue doing them
online
they'll have all the data they'll have
all the meetings then they'll come to me
i have to make a decision i have to make
it quickly you know
or or it might even be about hiring or
firing some staff you know are we going
to hire these new people
are we going to open up this new
division and i've got to make a decision
i've got to make it quickly
and i've realized as time has gone on
how important this is
and i really believe and i'm sharing it
to you right now watching i really
believe
that if you want to be successful in
property if you want to build an empire
if you want to be successful in any
business you need to be able to make
decisions you need to be able to make
them quickly now in this video
i want to go through the process that i
use to make decisions i want to go
through the formulas that i use
to make decisions and the first thing is
this it's okay
to make a wrong decision i think one of
the reasons people are scared to make
decisions
and they delay it and they say oh think
about it i'll think about it
is because actually they're afraid to
make a decision because they don't trust
themselves
so the first thing is confidence and
also confidence
not just that you're going to always
succeed but confidence that it's okay to
fail
second thing is to say actually you know
what i'm going to make a decision i'm
going to make it quickly
but i need all the information i need
all the data in front of me
to in order to make an informed decision
so it's about
knowing you know and once you've done
that it just becomes very simple because
then once you've got all the data
i mean even yesterday okay yesterday i
ended up
somehow long story short i ended up
sat in front of a doctor and the doctor
asked me a question
okay it's a long story it's a long story
but basically
i pick okay i got a little tiny mole
here a little tiny mole
i always pick it i always pick it so i
went in and i spoke to uh
a doctor i said to him hey i want to
know i don't know if he's a doctor or
whatever he was i said
can you chop it off so i went in for a
consultation
cost me 50 pounds i said what's the
crack with this little little mole
i went in and he said to me he said yes
sir i can chop it off it would cost 350
pounds
it'll be safe and he went through the
scenario i was like okay cool so
what happens next then you know maybe uh
i'll come in and book an appointment or
i'll go away i'll go think about it like
how does it work he goes well
you can just pay right now and i'll chop
it up right now i was like whoa
whoa hold on a minute hold on a minute
um now
like you're literally going to get a
blade and you're going to you know chop
it burn it how does this work
so so i like to do this thing and this
is what i use all the time in business
when i'm buying real estate when i'm
hiring staff
all the time i have to make decisions
and i just do this i say firstly
what is the best case scenario
okay what's the best case secondly is
i'm going to say what is the worst case
now i need the information in front of
me i need to know the data i need to
know the facts i need enough information
to be able to look at what the best case
is what the worst case is
and then i'm also going to want to know
what is the
likely case once i know these three
pieces of information once i know
the best case the worst case the likely
case
i am almost in a position where i can
make a decision
you can probably guess what decision i
made by the way based on the plasters
all over my face
so so i'm sad i'm thinking okay well i'm
thinking what's the best case well the
best case
according to the doctor is that he's
gonna chop it off it's gonna take about
five minutes
and then after a couple days i'm just
going to have no more
i'll never pick again i'll look better
it won't be annoying
great that's the best case the worst
case
like what's the worst case the worst
case is they'll chop it off and it'll go
terribly wrong
it will hurt it will get infected it
will grow back
or even worse it won't grow back i just
have a little scar there forever
okay a little scar therefore i don't
want scar that's the worst case
and then there's the likely case which
is the oh chop off it's a small little
mole
all good okay so i'm like okay well what
happens
if the worst case happens is the worst
case gonna kill me is it gonna [ __ ]
me am i going to lose my legs am i going
to lose my wife and kids am i going to
be bankrupt
well let's face it if it gets infected
it's a bit painful even if i'm left with
a little scar
at the moment i got a little more a
little sky a little more who cares it's
not a big deal
so the worst case isn't really that bad
the best case yeah cool cool it's great
and the likely case come on it's all
going to be okay so that's the first
part of decision making
once you've done that best case worst
case likely case
i then do something called what would
what would i advise my best friend to do
i had to do this when i was starting out
in property the first time i went into
an estate agency i remember
standing outside the station shop window
thinking i don't want to go inside i'm
scared i'm nervous
should i go in or should i go into that
state agency or should i just go home
and most people just i don't know what
to do and they'll do nothing
because it's like an uh powerless by
analysis or analysis by paralysis
okay so i'm thinking okay well what's
the best case i'll go into the estate
agency
and they'll give me a deal and it'll be
my the first deal towards building an
empire
amazing what's the worst case the worst
case is i'll go in
they'll say no we haven't got any deals
they'll kick me out and i'll look stupid
and i'll feel embarrassed for a couple
minutes
and what's the likely case the likely
case is they won't have any deals i'll
learn a couple things i'll grow my
confidence
and they might give me a lead in a
couple months down the line
cool so once i've got this information
i need the information now i need to
know what the best case if the doctor
said to me
oh the worst case scenario if i was to
chop your mold off would be
i'm not sure i don't know what the worst
case is then i'm like okay well
i'm not making a decision because i've
got to know what the worst case is
if i know what the worst case is within
reason
we could always get hit by a bus the
worst case could be i could
i could i could i could sit down in the
chair to have it chopped off and then i
could slip and break my neck and die but
that's not realistic
so the best case the worst case the
likely case within the realms of
realistic okay not being crazy not being
fearful
okay so next is i'm going to say great
now i know this information
what would i advise my best friend to do
i call this the best friend rule
if i want my best friend to win what
would i advise them to do
if i am talking to a friend they're
about to go into an estate agency but
they're scared and they're thinking
should i should i know i'm going to say
what's the best case what's the worst
case
then what would i advise them to do well
i'd probably say go do it so i went and
did it
i'm thinking my mole what's the worst
case what's the best case
worst case is i have a little scar worst
cases i'll chop it it'll grow back i'll
have wasted a few hundred quid
what the heck i'll do it so i'm lying
there i'm i'm getting ready to get this
thing chopped off and he goes
you've got another couple little moles
i'm like have i i look at the mirror i'm
like now i've noticed he said you want
me to chop them off too
because it's really really cheap because
now you've got the wand and i'm here
anyway
it's going to cost a couple of extra and
i was just like you know what
forget it i'm just going to make a fast
decision chop them all off so that's why
by the way
this whole video was really just a big
disclaimer an excuse as to why
i got all these little plasters on my
face okay i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding
so what would i advise my best friend to
do if it was my best friend sitting
there i'd probably say
don't be a [ __ ] oh just get your mold
chopped off you keep picking it it's
annoying it's a few hundred quid get it
chopped off it's gonna be fine the trust
the doctor it's okay
so i made that decision when i'm making
decisions about
hiring or firing people buying new deals
buying the castle
it's okay if i buy the castle best case
i'll make millions of pounds
worst case it'll be a pain i'll end up
selling it and i won't make any money
like the case
i'll make seven figures what would i
advise my best friend to do
i'd probably just say just go do it okay
well in that case now
i'm just gonna act fast i'm gonna say
five four three two one go
i'm gonna make a decision and constantly
in my life
i'm making fast decisions and here's
something i really really believe
on your deathbed okay firstly when you
die your tombstone is gonna have two
dates and a dash
and the dash little dash is called that
little thing called life
everything that you and i know life is
so short and on our deathbed before we
die
i don't think we're going to be looking
back with regret saying i wish i'd done
less
i wish i'd not made those rash decisions
i wish i'd done less i wish i'd taken
less action
i think when we die we're going to say i
wish i'd done more if only i'd done that
when i had the opportunity
i mean literally i've known people that
are such poor decision makers
i've offered to give them a free house
i've been like hey do you want a house
for free
sign here and and look you'll get you'll
get my house
and they've been like oh did you think
about it oh i need to speak to my wife
oh
he's like but it's a free house look at
the best case worst case like what's the
worst case
like literally come on get real but most
people
cannot make decisions and i believe
that's what's keeping people poor on
your deathbed you're going to say i wish
i did more
not i wish you did less so that's my
topic today
do more don't do less make decisions
and make fast decisions i mean it's such
a shame that in 2020
most people when they're 26 years old
are just playing playstation living with
their mom at home
not having to make big decisions no and
honestly it just freaks me out so
that's my thoughts that's my opinion
that's what how i'm living i am a
full-time decision maker i make them
fast
what do you think comment below and i
look forward to seeing you on the next
video peace out